all right the mega millions jackpot is
now 660 million dollars it's actually
one of the biggest prizes ever and the
drawing is coming up in just a few hours
at eight o'clock yes we sent las vegas
now it's julian lopez to the lotto store
in prim to catch all of that excitement
jillian
hi you guys yes it's very exciting out
here and you're right if someone wins
this mega millions tonight it will be
the third largest mega millions ever so
it's a really big deal and i am among a
lot of people in line out here who are
hopeful of winning that mega millions
and i gotta tell you the line actually
hasn't been too bad people have been
waiting on average about 20 to 30
minutes so not too bad especially given
the heat but i did find a hopeful family
who has
obviously hoping to win this mega
millions lotto tonight i'm here with
juan and lilan you guys this is the 600
million dollar question but what would
you do with the money if you won
first off i donate what i can to the
church in my first 10
and then of course i would invest some
of it and of course put up some money in
the savings for my little one here so
yeah lelone is there something you want
to buy if you won hundreds of millions
of dollars
maybe a new toy yeah that's what i
thought all right give me a high five if
you think you're gonna win tonight
that's right all right you can hear the
cheers in here everyone is really
excited and i actually made friends with
someone in line who said that buying a
lottery ticket isn't just a lotto ticket
it's a ticket to dream because even just
for one day you can imagine what you
would do with hundreds of millions of
dollars so the the drawing is happening
tonight 11 p.m eastern 8 p.m our time
the office is closed at 5 pm here so
things are you know finishing up but
everyone's excited we're waiting i got
my tickets in my pocket so i'll continue
to bring you guys coverage throughout
the rest of the day but we're really
hoping that someone will win that 660
million dollar mega jackpot tonight and
hey hopefully it's someone here in las
vegas for now i'll send it back to you
yes